Are you going to
answer that?
It's not mine.
Hello, Matt.
Sorry, who is this?
There is a bomb
under your seat.
If you...
Do I have your
attention?
Did I do something
to you?
You sound so
guilty.
What do you want?
Drive
to this location.
Honey,
something's
happened.
There's a man who
has put a bomb
in the car.
Under our seats,
there are pressure
triggers.
We can't get out.
The car will explode.
We're here.
Listen very carefully
or I kill you.
Open the glovebox.
Shoot him.
Why are you
doing this?
What have I ever
done to you?
Dad.
His life
or yours.
Matt.
I'm your best friend.
You're a murderer
now, Matt.
You think I'm
the bomber.
Well, I guess you've
had a tough day.
I know
that you lost a
lot of money
for your clients
who invested in
your fund.
No!
A lot of people are
worried about you.
You've got everybody's
attention, Matt.
He is still out there.
If you can't find him,
I will.
I am in control here.
No you're not!
You hurt my
daughter,
you son of a bitch.
I will kill you.
What's it gonna be?
Drive.